guess how many people quit their jobs
today how many what do you think a
thousand five thousand maybe ten
thousand what if I told you a hundred
thousand people quit their jobs today
and what if I told you three million
Americans quit their jobs every single
month and if you're an employee running
a company what can you do about it we're
gonna talk about it today okay so before
I give you ten things you can do as an
employer to retain employees let's first
talk about some stats having to do with
retention here's what we got first one
I've already shared with you three
million employees could every single
month in America
number two cost of replacing a
well-trained employee meaning here's
Bobby he's been with me three years I've
trained him he knows what he's doing he
makes $75,000 per year if I want to
replace Bobby it's gonna cost me
exceeding two hundred percent of his
salary just to replace a meaning I
replace Bobby with Jacquie I have to
spend a hundred and fifty thousand
dollars on top of Jacquie salary that's
how much a highly trained employee costs
this if you replace them number three
employees who are engaged and thriving
are 59 percent less likely to look for a
job with a different organization in the
next twelve months meaning what if I'm
engaged hey you got me going with a
project what are we working over here
and I'm thriving I'm going to the next
level good things are happening 59
percent less like they're going on jobs
calm and looking for another job in last
but not least very important cuz we're
gonna talk about later on today bad boss
performance makes employees four times
more likely to quit one more time bad
boss performance makes employees four
times more likely to quit so what does
bad boss performance means maybe you got
somebody that's working with your guys
he is not a good boss she is not a good
boss and everybody on the team are
quitting because it's bad boss the bad
boss is now leaving their people
properly we're gonna talk about that
here in a minute if you want any of
these stats we're gonna put the links
below second thing to talk about here is
distractions of you to boss your
employer to you the CEO distractions of
retaining employees today the first one
is a great economy
whenever economy is doing very good it's
hard to retain people why because
everybody goes shopping with their
resume hey I make seventy two thousand
dollars a year here can you give me 80
hey I make sixty eight thousand dollars
you give me 75 I'll come to you hey I
make eighty-five you give me six because
I'm coming to you so they're shopping
because it's a great economy companies
have cash it's a great time to go shop
your resume so it becomes tough to
retain people number two is not speaking
the language of the new generation so
imagine as everybody's getting older
SEOs going from 25 30 35 40 45 50 as
he's 50 he knows how to speak the 40
year old language 45 50 55 60 but maybe
he doesn't have to speak to 22 year old
language or 28 or 33 so if you don't
learn how to adjust what the language
retention goes down because you don't
how to speak that language you got to
learn the language they speak in must
when I say language I'm not talking
about like Mandarin or Spanish I'm
talking about the language the interest
of that generation next social media
next side gigs if I'm working for you
and I got a side gig making six thousand
dollars a month or three thousand
dollars a month or five thousand dollars
a month the threat of losing my job is
no longer at the level of 99 oh my gosh
I don't want to make my boss man what if
I lose him because that person's got a
side view you want to fire me no problem
I'm making $5,000 a month part-time
that's another enemy that people are
facing today last but not least its
competition there's a lot of companies
today that if you don't do your part as
a company you can lose employees to your
competitor because they're doing a
better job retaining people than you are
the whole proposition they have is
better than you so those are some of the
things you're facing retention and some
of the distractions in the marketplace
now 10 things you can do to retain
employees number one build stronger
mid-level management what am I talking
about so let's look at this the CEO has
the CFO has the director has the
employees that report to the director
right many times if you're the CEO lets
you see your good CEO you hire a CFO and
the CFO comes from a place that's pretty
organized was with a formal company for
15 years somehow somewhere you're able
to persuade him to come and be your CFO
then he brings middle management the
challenge would losing employees is the
director or the VP whoever's at this
level
properly trained on how to deal with
employees and their team members and
their losing people but you don't know
why you're losing people because
mid-level management needs some help so
you have to focus on mid-level
management now what do you do with this
we'll talk about that here in a minute
number two is recruiting people that
match your culture
I have many times found somebody who I
looked at this guy that was one guy
recruiter I'm like oh my gosh this guy's
a beast he's absolutely incredible I
wish he would work with us but he
wouldn't this was many many years ago he
wouldn't because our culture doesn't fit
his personality and his personality
doesn't fit our culture if I try to
force him into our culture it's just not
gonna work out so I recommend him in
another company he went very happy that
get for himself here's what it was our
culture let's just he have a family
environment what's a family culture hey
we kind of run together as family you
know it's a very caring environment hey
Bobby how you doin house family has
everybody great number two is flexible
we're flexible you want to come in at
8:30 it's cool as long as you get the
job done you know it's gonna be fine
we have a very competitive your your if
you're on time you're late you know if
we say the clock you got to be here by
7:00 55 maybe 7:30 you know what are you
doing leaving early you got to stay
little later that's the competitive
environment right a lot of Silicon
Valley some of the financial industry
some of the sales business has got to be
very competitive to make it right next
one is hierarchy any reason why you came
into my office do you know who I am do
you realize I run the department here
have you spoken to your director yet
please don't come to my office again
unless if you speak to your director his
name is Bobby Jones go talk to Bobby
Jones don't come to me again thank you
thank you please get the door behind you
thank you great job by the way on your
project last month
that's hearty now there are multi
multi-billion auto companies out there
that run on different kind of cultures
but we're talking about retaining people
to your company right if you force
somebody that doesn't fit into your
culture you're gonna lose them and not
only are you gonna lose them you're
gonna frustrate them more important you
gonna frustrate yourself so you got to
ask yourself what is our culture that's
the right question of the people you're
recruiting that fit into your culture
then say this could possibly work don't
force people into your culture it's
gonna be disastrous number three
hire the best or have the best
leadership development program let me
explain to you for instance if I
automatically can't afford
I have money you have resources you got
money saved if you can't afford to go
hire the best go hire the best if the
difference is one forty gets you one of
the best but to 20 gets you the best on
top of the world that additional $80,000
you're gonna make up and a return that
person is gonna bring to the company
don't be cheap in that place if you know
this person is the best in every
possible way go hire the best now you
may not be able to afford it if you
can't afford to hire the best you got to
have a strong leadership development
program to be able to take somebody from
a $42,000 to $82,000 person to one
hundred thirteen thousand dollars
$173,000 because you're developing their
identity based on the leadership program
that you have so now when we say this
here's what I do
whether it's sales okay whether it's
home office whether it's support whether
it's directors whether it's executive
whether it's carriers partners no matter
who I'm working with I always look
around and I say okay who fits the
culture the best this guy does he's bad
and he's a true believer he's a worker
he gets it he's a great student he's
coachable strong character I trust him
integrity competencies there I like this
person I am locking on to this person to
shape their mindset and I'm putting 90
percent of my time to develop this
person because if this person comes here
now I'm retaining employees so what if I
move him up and he becomes a leader I
don't have to not worry about because he
already knows the psychology on how to
work with people and as the person moves
up within the company I'm not too
worried because I develop them the right
way so again if you can afford to hire
the best go over pay to get hire the
best but if you can't create an
incredible leadership development system
where you know people who come through
your model your company they move up
next number four empower them to make
decisions what does this mean it could
be different levels of decisions you got
to make well you can get back on that
person with an email if somebody asks a
question on this level you can just get
back to him you don't need my approval
you know if it comes out to money you're
a director you can spend up to ten
thousand dollars we're just needing a
signature but it's you if it's a hundred
thousand dollar CF or you can do your
so if it's a half-a-million-dollar this
seal can make the decision himself not
needing the board and anything above the
half a million dollars board makes the
decisions a five million dollar
investment we need the board's approval
if it's a fifty million dollar
but find a way to empower them for
decisions where employees are sitting
there saying I'm not just having
somebody hover over me 24/7 where I feel
like I can't do anything give them the
flexibility and empower them to make
some decisions they will feel more
ownership and the fact that you trust
them they move up they do better number
five match qualities needed based on
department meaning I've hired people and
I've put them in a certain Department
where I watch them and I say man this is
not gonna work out what the quality this
person has he's too aggressive way too
aggressive the department you're a part
of it's customer service hi thank you
for calling you know such and such how
may I help you
oh that's no problem mr. Jones I'm here
to help you out so can you share with me
this information please I totally
understand your frustration I apologize
about that I'd be more than happy to
help you out can you tell me a little
bit more about this part are you on the
website do you have the phone with you
great look mr. Jones I'm here to help
you out right very accommodating what a
great personality right now imagine you
put your type-a personalities to do
customer service yes what's happens to
Jones how you doing yeah yeah okay yeah
okay cut them off cut them off cut them
off yeah okay me what's the big deal
everybody has problems nowadays with
customer service what why yeah I mean I
get it but and then boom I said oh whoa
whoa whoa whoa buddy it's a different
strength you may be competitive you got
to work in a different department but
you got to be behind the scenes many
times I'll go to a restaurant and I'll
tell Mario I say that guy hostess not a
hostess that guy needs to be behind the
scenes you can't be in the front
touching customers he's a terrible
hostess you ever met hostess that are
like this yes what's your name
what time's your red did you have
reservation okay hang on 7:00 p.m. okay
hang on we'll get to you in a minute
that's not a hostess but that person can
be better in a different place that
person cannot be the first person
shaking hands right so you got to make
sure your positioning people with
qualities that match the department's
and if it doesn't match you got to let
them go but matching the department
number six ask who they want to be today
on a conference call I'm doing one of my
guys asked me question saying
do you get the most out of people I said
what do you mean tell me more so he
starts telling well I can't get a
certain group of people in my office to
get excited what do I do to get him
excited I said let me ask you a question
he says what's that I said where do you
want to be by next September 20 20 at
our annual convention at MGM Grand Arena
we do this once here the last one we did
we had President Bush and Kobe Ryan
there Jordan Peterson all these guys
next one's gonna be MGM Grand Arena what
do you want to be by then and he says
well I'd like to be at such-and-such
place his wife is also on the phone s
okay what what level would you like to
be well what would you like to be
recognized for what are some things
you'd like to experience for yourself
and then he starts asking saying all
this stuff I said what what things will
you reward yourself with if you reach
those milestones what selfish words are
gonna reward yourself and he started
talking he got excited and then at the
end five minutes of me going through
these questions with him I said do you
remember what question you asked me he
says no what was the question
I said you asked me a question how to
get your people to move and how you can
motivate them I said do you realize what
I just did to you is what you got to do
to your people he says I never thought
about it that way I said how do you feel
right now Felix Eddie said man I'm so
excited I said you got to go out and do
the same thing with the folks you're
working with which means what a very
basic question hey Bobby look what do
you want to be here what do you want to
do tell me you're gonna be here you're
gonna be here you want to be here I can
see you being here but if you want to be
here you got to do X Y Z you know what I
really want to be here
well great if you do these are some of
the areas you got to work on you're good
in this but you got some work you got to
do here and you're not as consistent in
these four areas but if you want to go
do you got to show me these things okay
and if you do the following things we
can consider moving into this place
great but I asked the question based on
what who do they want to be you want to
move your people to retain ask your
people regularly who do they want to be
I will tell you so many bosses don't ask
their people who they want to be they
keep losing people because people are
just trying to do what pleases them at
the end of it you got to ask them who do
you want to be next clear set of
qualities values and principles that the
company values meaning here's what we
value as a company and we talked about
in the hiring interview these are the
things we
and four do you like it I do great do
you like it no no problem all the best
you but rather than for sink we now
attract people who value our values and
principles and the way we get to people
that value our values and principles is
by talking about it and when you talk
about it you'll know in an interview
somebody says oh my gosh that's very
important to me
or you see somebody that goes like this
ya know this is not gonna work maybe
needing to go to a different place right
and that's totally fine but I can't
force you into our culture next number
eight strong training program remember
earlier when I said building a strong
mid-level management and at the bottom
here we talked about the fact that hire
the best if not have a strong leadership
program so these two go with the strong
training program so for me one of our
guys right now she's the chief
reputation officer I sent her to Harvard
she's in Harvard while I'm making this
video she's in Harvard we spend fifteen
thousand dollars to send her to Harvard
but no problem she's going to Harvard we
just gave her a promotion we're excited
about her going over there
why because I'm trying to get her to see
a complete different scope of things by
having all these different case studies
she goes through and she comes back has
he been developed we sent a few of our
guys to Wharton Business School we send
our guys to Adobe that has its one week
or four day course we'll spend a few
thousand dollars and send our guys there
because we're in the game of constant
development we spent a few thousand
dollars the other day had all of our
directors go through a two-day program
that's about becoming better on how to
deal work with people and it showed how
to communicate with talkers doers all
these different personalities approaches
how to hold them accountable how to
excite them how to get the most out of
them we invest in these things regularly
and then people come back and come out
of it right and then there's monthly
accountability on how to develop these
leaders this is all more on investing
into your training program this is an
area sometimes people wing it companies
wink it and then they wonder why do I
keep losing people why do I have such a
weak mid-management
middle management because you don't
invest into a lot of your training this
this you have to be very detailed and
and its strategic about it can't just
wing it go read this book go read that
book you can't just wing it you got to
be specific about it next constantly
emphasize read see sometimes when I
work with leaders we have life going on
I got three kids I'm married I got
family issues happens right we had a
tornado that hit just yesterday right
whether it's not good craziness building
comes down you know we have a lose a
couple agents somebody passes away over
here we have issues with a certain
vendor a partner a carrier all of these
things and if you're not too careful
you will be beat up so much what are you
kind of like oh my gosh oh it's another
day to come to work oh my god I'm just
beat Oh what else do I have to do in
those moments you got to figure out a
way to re-read this entire game is read
to retain re-energize retain restate
division recast where we're going
re kindled the relationship that had a
falling out it's reading is really mind
riri mine re remind over and over and
over and over again and then eventually
guess who else is doing that your CFO
your directors they're in the game of
Ria's well right great parents reinforce
great leaders reinforce hey guys come
here
like yesterday Patriots I'm looking at
the ESPN earlier this morning
the fact that their team is already
shutting down New York Jets and Bill
Belichick is sitting there talking to
the defense game is over with what are
you doing but he's reinforcing because
he knows they're seven I know they're
gonna go into the playoffs he's trying
to get because they have the best
defense so far for the year he's
reinforcing the defense what are you
doing that's why he's who he is Bill
Belichick hey guys have bodies watching
and what he's doing that's why people
follow a guy like that and that's why
he's got so many Super Bowls because
he's in the regain leadership is all
about read constantly without getting
tired burned out all my guys stamina I'm
not in the mood today you don't have the
responsibility of being in the mood or
not because you chose to be a leader the
moment you choose to be a leader you
lose that privilege of hey you know I'm
also gonna go out there and be upset
about everything that's going on with
the company recipe for losing a lot of
people got a stay level-headed if you
got to find a way to go out and release
and do your own release whatever that
may be do it but make sure you don't do
it around your people where you have a
blow-up and you lose a couple employees
and last but not least transparency of
challenges every Monday morning
we'll have a huddle here and we'll get
up here's what we were last week wasn't
a good week you know here's what read so
far for the month last month we did
better than this one we got to kind of
get some things together hey guess what
this one this week we had a
record-breaking week crazy out to this
department phenomenal to that department
that department we got some work to do
over here and then that department will
turn on so but we're coming we got some
stuff coming up great but it's open hey
here's the thing that we're looking for
that department needs help if anybody is
trying to go to a different department
and unilateral move we're looking we
need some help in this department but
it's transparent where people are like
wow I trust this environment there's not
a lot of games where everything is good
everything is perfect because that's
fake you know it can't be perfect
there's always issues believe it or not
a certain level of try I'm not telling
you go put up two checkbooks and say hey
guys we only have thirteen thousand
dollars in the checking account but
stick around we may make it when I went
to $13,000 in the checking account with
the company I was running and we almost
lost everything nine years ago I wasn't
going around telling everybody I may not
be able to pay your payroll next week
you know I just wanna let you guys know
that you know but we're gonna figure
this out I tell you this one we're gonna
figure this out no but certain
challenges we were facing we talked
about it because you share pressure and
believe it or not when the people see
that there's certain challenges taking
place people wanna come say hey I'll
come and help out
hey we're not beating these guys they're
ahead of us by this much I want to rise
that what do we need to do hey we're
number seven we'd like to get our number
six but I got some work to do guys we
got to really pick it up hey let's go so
it gives opportunities for people to
rise up and more people that could
potentially move up within your company
again you have some stats you have some
enemies you have ten things to do
to retain people in your company I've
got two videos I want you to watch I'd
have to do with this topic number one
how to pay your employees there's four
ways you pay your employees and it's
specific ways of doing it to make sure
you retain your best employees and the
second thing I want you to watch it's a
video I did a few years ago maybe three
four years ago titled twenty four ways
to improve your company culture okay if
you want to figure out a way how to pay
your employees watch this if you want to
figure out whether I'll improve your
company culture watch this year but
either way if you haven't subscribed to
the channel please do so and if you got
any thoughts comment below or tweet me
directly at Patrick
David take care everybody bye-bye